Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Style transfer is an interesting problem in
machine learning research where we have two
input images, one for content, and one for
style, and the output is our content image
reimagined with this new style.
The cool part is that the content can be a
photo straight from our camera, and the style
can be a painting, which leads to super fun,
and really good looking results.
We have seen plenty of papers doing variations
of style transfer, but can we can push this
concept further?
And the answer is, yes!
For instance, few people know that style transfer
can also be done in 3D!
If you look here, you see an artist performing
this style transfer by drawing on a simple
sphere and get their artistic style to carry
over to a complicated piece of 3D geometry.
We talked about this technique in Two Minute
Papers episode 94, and for your reference,
we are currently at over episode 340.
Leave a comment if you’ve been around back
then!
And this previous technique led to truly amazing
results, but still had two weak points.
One, it took too long.
As you see here, this method took around a
minute or more to produce these results.
And hold on to your papers, because this new
paper is approximately a 1000 times faster
than that, which means that it can produce
100 frames per second using a whopping 4K
resolution.
But of course, none of this matters… if
the visual quality is not similar.
And, if you look closely, you see that the
new results are indeed really close to the
reference results of the older method.
So, what was the other problem?
The other problem was the lack of temporal
coherence.
This means that when creating an animation,
it seems like each of the individual frames
of the animation were drawn separately by
an artist.
In this new work, this is not only eliminated
as you see here, but the new technique even
gives us the opportunity to control the amount
of flickering.
With these improvements, this is is now a
proper tool to help artists perform this 3D
style transfer and create these rich virtual
worlds much quicker and easier in the future.
It also opens up the possibility for novices
to do that, which is an amazing value proposition.
Limitations still apply, for instance, if
we have a texture with some regularity, such
as this brickwall pattern here, the alignment
and continuity of the bricks on the 3D model
may suffer.
This can be fixed, but it is a little labor-intensive.
However, you know our saying, two more papers
down the line, and this will likely cease
to be an issue.
And what you’ve seen here today is just
one paper down the line from the original
work, and we can do 4K resolution at a 100
frames per second.
Unreal.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!